can you guys speak to like there's
always like a on
told like rivalry between Northern
California and Southern California and
I'm not keep hearing about that I never
heard of one ever in my life ever like
out of my 35 years in hip-hop music
putting music on the show I have never
now if you want to talk about BR before
that before rap for our streets I don't
think it was a rival it was just the
game it's the streets you know what I
mean there's a little Funk going on in
prisons
never been in hip-hop not hip-hop it's
always been supportive I think uh I
think we admire each other
for what we don't do you know uh
the energy the the flavor
um that that Northern California Bay
Area artists bring is something
different new fresh I'm always looking
forward to seeing what it is and it's
different than the Southern California
flavor and um and I think vice versa you
know
um they hear stuff from from down here
that they like oh damn they don't they
own a whole new new page you know we
we saw similar but we we different it's
like cousins you know
y'all blood related but your household
is a little different than your cousin's
household I do feel like the bay is like
the I mean the most underratedly
influential region in all of rap if you
just think of Life
sonically slaying I mean you know I
think of like a guy's like the pack how
they influence the whole generation like
10 or 12 years ago like obviously 40
short you guys are you know on the mount
Westmore for sure
um
obviously the the record with pilo on it
very Bay Area uh I feel like I'm like
who's kind of picking the Beats who's
kind of helped a r in it and like would
you guys say it is like a
which region sonically is winning the
Bayer LA on the album we had to have a
balance it had to come from different
ways so you listened to if you heard the
album listen to the song have a nice day
uh [ __ ] You song it's definitely that's
definitely like Dr Dre influence
produced by Fred Ruckus shout out to
Fred Rick uh lace you up definitely like
SoCal all day activated nice you know
it's it's on there and then you know you
got songs that are on the extreme other
spectrum of like uh free game and and uh
yeah basically I mean the two big
records of strip baby shout out to
pillow that's my bro but at the same
time if you leave the state of
California we're here if you leave here
they their ears just here West Coast
they're sure you don't hear that little
distinct you're right it's that a Bay
Area person an LA person with here in
the song and I think that uh the West
Coast when you get us all in the same
room
we stand up together we always have you
you put uh Warren G and DJ Quick in the
room that we all we West Coast we
California boys we like we ride together
like for us it's not on basketball
obviously Sports and stuff you know you
gotta you gotta have it we're all riding
with the big three but when it comes to
like you know the professional teams
yeah but we definitely uh feed off each
other off the bay in the bay we got a
lot of Dr Dre Islams in Bay Area Music
we got a lot from Trey you know what I'm
saying uh recently I think uh you know
producers like uh like like mustard he
kind of like you know grabbed a little
bit of that bay energy and into a
certain way of course we don't got a
gang or lingo from the bay yeah but yeah
for sure so it's like it's just we we
are one but like you said we like
cousins and there is no Feud don't I
have not seen the feud or the
competition right who could come with
the hottest records we really and our
young rappers when you get the the g e
Z's and all them come out they hanging
out with the Kendricks they know it
ain't no
have you guys had the bipin talk with
Snoop and Cube about when you guys go do
promo in the bay like don't leave
nothing in the car leave your room they
know what they already know because they
besides us Cube and Snoop they got Bay
Area fam too
we all locked in we all yeah that's
another thing yeah that's what I'm
saying the warranty got real blood
cousins
in Oakland yeah
I I was born I got cousins I got cousins
in Inglewood like I got cousins all over
the place I was born on Sunset Boulevard
man that's crazy I got a whole million
first cousins in LA